The Joe Rogan experience,
um,
is there anything in this episode
or this issue that deals with a very
controversial issue of antidepressants
and their effect on the human mind?
People asking about about that?
So,
you know,
anti psychotics,
here's one thing that I'll say about
or Ssri or not anti psychotics,
sorry,
not Ssri.
I don't have good informed
opinion on antidepressant,
on antidepressants.
I just don't know enough about it.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't know how to
comment on that intelligently.
I will say that,
you know,
anti psychotics,
which are a sort of,
you know,
an extreme thing,
right?
There's all kinds of,
of uh,
you know,
incredible research being done,
but we're still,
it's still very early days
in our understanding of
what drugs do to the brain
and what happens here and there.
And so,
you know,
anti psychotics,
there's,
there was a statistically
significant group of people in a,
I think God,
I'm going to miss represent this,
but no,
basically I was talking to a university
professor who had done this study about,
um,
she was a clinical psychologist who had
done a study about people taking out our
psychotics and a certain number of,
of,
uh,
the patients were so transformed by this
new generation of anti psychotics that
they did,
that they voluntarily went off them to
go back to the hallucinations that they'd
had before.
Wow.
It's not a lot of people.
I don't want to necessarily
represent the number,
but it was a statistically
significant group of people,
which means that there are people who,
for whatever reason,
their reaction is I would rather.
So in one of the cases
that you described was a,
uh,
a man,
a homeless man who believed that he
was being pursued by the Russians,
you know,
and was living in stark terror in this
kind of cold war nightmare every waking
moment.
And he was homeless and
Dorothy but just ruined guy.
He goes and he gets begins to get this
anti psychotic medication and these,
and it turns off not
just your hallucinations,
but it also maintains your
ability to reason and function.
You know,
it can be very helpful sometimes if it,
if it works,
and I'd like to point out
that's not always true.
Um,
but he was so destabilized by
discovering that nobody wanted him.
The Russians didn't want him,
nobody wanted them.
Right now he's just a bum dude.
And he was,
he was bummed out because,
because he wasn't special anymore.
Right.
He was the star of his own
action movie for so long,
you know,
and add more guy and he and
he voluntarily went back to,
to being,
to living that life,
you know,
he took the blue pill and then whatever
it was and then wished you hadn't.
Well,
I would like to see what he saw before
I made any sort of a judgment on them
because who knows,
he might have been living in an awesome
world like a winnie the Pooh ride.
Totally neon colors everywhere and
fucking Russian agents hiding behind two
dimensional trees.
Marriage driving a convertible.
Yeah,
I mean,
who knows what he actually saw a,
there was this conversation on,
on the board recently where
I brought up the thing about,
uh,
if you had a thousand
monkeys on typewriters,
eventually they would write the works of,
given an infinite number
of time or amount of time.
I think that's horseshit.
But it is true because an
infinite number of time.
Yeah,
because if you had like,
let's just take out the monkeys and
say you have one computer program,
did you imagine that a monkey really did?
Right.
Like Romeo and Juliet,
you just left this monkey in a fucking
room at a typewriter and most of it was
dog shit.
Most of them will say,
why?
Why?
But one day that monkey just got it right
and his little fucking eyes rolled in
the back of his head like a slot machine.
He starts typing.
I didn't even notice it.
It just can't even right at the end of
midsummer night's dream Romeo but not.
I mean,
the question is,
you know,
like say you,
you're randomly selecting characters.
Each character is randomly selected and
you do this for an infinite string of
characters.
Then not only would you get the
entire works of Shakespeare,
but you would get an
infinite number of times.
You would get it backwards and infinite
number of times you would get every
chapter in every order,
an infinite number of times you would get
everything that's ever been written in
every single order that you could ever
think to put it in an infinite number of
times by my sweat.
Infinite that monkeys.
Well,
why would he is on a
typewriter with chimps?
Yeah,
there they wouldn't
hurt the little fingers.
Monkeys.
They're little tiny.
Yeah,
man.
That's the word in it.
Yeah.
Even that doesn't even begin
to describe it in that,
that that word is a real
problem where we don't really.
That doesn't register with me
when I say infinite on my face.
It's goes until I can think
about it and then it keeps going.
I mean even just like when you see
those videos of like they sent a probe,
like an artificial prob like to show
you what it looks like when they leave
earth and then it sees the moon,
then it sees the other outer
planets and then it sees,
you know,
the,
the galaxy from a distance
and it keeps going and going.
That doesn't work.
It doesn't get in there.
I mean there are so fucking far away
when you have to start thinking about the
speed of light.
Like the fact that the son
is eight light minutes away.
Mars is like 30 light minutes away.
Pluto is like 18 hours
away in terms of lights.
Will Dr. Greer is going to let us know,
goodness,
how big the universe is when he reveals
what the aliens have been telling him.
Garth brooks is slowly
becoming some classics.
So like,
you know,
you have classic rock.
I got friends in low places.
Could be a classes that you saw.
It's weird you say that because I was
at the capital records building a while
ago just to get a friend to work
there and they had this place,
these plaques on the wall and like
every album that sold 10 million copies,
right.
Which is not that many.
So you go to the capitol records,
there were like four Beatles records,
dark side of the moon and
just a wall of Garth Brooks,
like you don't realize how many fucking
albums and he had like six albums that
sold 10.
Like you wonder why you don't hear from
anymore because he's got more fucking
money than indie music doing vegas now.
I think he started doing
the concerts in Vegas,
but just with an acoustic guitar I
think really like it's just him with a
guitar.
Yeah.
Listen,
he's a weird fuck,
but he's undeniably talented.
You can't sell that many records
and not have something going on.
I've got friends in low places
is a great fucking song.
If you got a buzz on and that song
comes on and you don't get happy your
account.
Well,
if you're that,
that's a little harsh,
but I.
I agree,
but now where I'm from,
if you're,
if you're drinking and somebody
doesn't put that on the Jukebox,
like something's wrong,
I cannot take that,
so
of course he can't.
You're from Ohio.
You probably heard it every day.
Your life,
your alarm clock,
every day.
You remember when he did that weird thing
garth brooks did where he put on a wig
and pretend to be a different dude.
He was Chris.
Chris Gaines was that.
It was God.
That was the weirdest thing ever.
Fuck was that about when I see those
plaques on the wall at capital records,
I'm like,
no wonder he did that.
He was just like,
come on man.
Who Let.
Who let you do that?
Garth Brooks,
and he grew a little flavor.
Savor a little flavor
saver onto the lower lip.
Anyway,
total emo,
Weirdo brooding.
That looks like he was in
an argument with his label.
He's like,
look,
you fuckers,
I could sell albums doing anything.
I'll fuck.
I want to change my name.
Put a goat,
and then that's what he thought.
He really did believe that.
I think that was.
Was that his last album?
Boy,
that's a shitty way to go out.
If that's his last.
That was like the pictures
of them all with the hair.
Just perfectly fine.
If we don't know it's a fucking wig man.
You can't just wear a wig.
Okay.
That's ridiculous.
That looks member for a while and snl.
That was like the Goto joke was on weekend
update with every joke because like
Chris gave gaines fucking silly.
He is the idea that he thought that he
could pretend to be someone different,
a different personality.
I'm not the happy country guy anymore
even though it's the same guy inside my
heart when I'm Chris Gaines.
I'm moody as fuck.
Okay.
I'm all dressed in black and
we'll flavor say even died.
That and my hair.
It's all thick and heavy even
though you know I'm going bald.
Don't think about that.
Don't think about the wig,
man.
Think about the persona.
I'm trying to sell a persona.
I got this down.
It's Goddamn character.
You've got to love my new CD.
It's Chris Gaines is moody as fuck.
That's what it's called.
I want you to concentrate.
I want you to concentrate
on the shitty music.
This time my shitty looks to me,
but one heart you.
Oh,
do we become when mood together and
like see who wrote these shitty songs,
Chris Gaines or Greg Brooks,
but don't know.